pour tout le monde des questions
auxquelles julien peut prendre la
manoeuvre comment désinfection les
douches à l'ego depuis quelques jours
c'est dans ce gymnase du xiiie
arrondissement parisien qu'ont lieu les
briefings de jérôme peyrat le complexe
sportif abrite désormais une base
logistique des membres de la protection
civile
et tout a été aménagé pour faciliter
leurs missions
coli on va rentrer dans la zone de
douche les vestiaires accueille
désormais les secouristes ici on a les
lots de douche cheminement est
matérialisée au sol pour que la zone
propre et la zone salles soient séparés
une fois que les équipiers sont rentrés
les sorties parce qu'une fois que le
premier entre évidemment on considère
que la zone sa poitrine et n'est plus
totalement dans ce coin douche laverie a
été aménagé qui permit aux choristes
donc en fin de mission de venir déposer
ses affaires personnelles et récupère
éventuellement le lendemain matin propre
sécher et le gymnase accueillant
habituellement les rencontres sportives
héberge désormais les secouristes il y a
même des lits de camp en cas de besoin
sur cette zone
de quoi faire reposer les secouristes et
puis pour ceux qui viendraient en qui
finirait leur service à 3 heures du
matin ils ont fait pas envie de rentrer
chez eux à trois heures du matin après
avoir fait deux heures de garde
ils peuvent rester ici jusqu'au
lendemain matin et ils ont de quoi
dormir et donc on a en a au moins un
permanent ifi qui passe toutes ses nuits
sur le site
si la protection civile s'est installé
ici c'est en premier lieu pour permettre
la désinfection des véhicules utilisés
lors des interventions
une étape indispensable après chaque
prise en charge d'une victime en fait
l'optique lassé de faire toutes les
surfaces
les affiches le plafond le sol on va
remettre entièrement levé le matériel
qui est dans la cabine avant une fois
que tout est sec
jusque là c'était dans la cour de
l'hôpital necker que 7 des infections
étaient réalisés mais face à la
surcharge des véhicules dans ce lieu il
a été décidé de trouver une solution
alternative
l'implantation dans ce complexe sportif
a permis de 10
minuit le temps d'immobilisation des
ambulances de la protection civile
multipliant par deux le nombre possible
d'intervention et ses crises de l'épopée
repenti pc crise parler dès les premiers
instants on a une activité qui est l
activité je veux dire que l'on ne peut
selon nous n'a jamais eu au cours de
l'histoire de l'association
on avait dans les premières semaines une
quinzaine de véhicules qui tournait de 8
heures le matin jusqu'à 3 heures le
lendemain matin en fait même si
l'activité des secouristes de la
protection civile décroît légèrement
il reste mobilisé ses bases logistiques
éphémère restera en place aussi
longtemps que durera le confinement